[Musique]
je cherche un mur pour pleurer
je cherche un mur pour pleurer on ne
pleure plus partie on avale tout c'est
facile on ne dit plus rien lorsqu'on
vous crache dessus
on reste sera la colère c'est mal vu
on est poli boli
on tend son cul merci merci je cherche
un maire pour pleurer
[Musique]
je cherche un mur pour plaire et hommes
on ne sait me plaît parait-il on dit que
l'amour est fragile pour les traits
modernes en laisse sa liberté mais on
fait les poches aussitôt le dos tourné
on n'est pas capable
on sera content
honteux rien
plus rien
je cherche jamais à pas pleurer
je cherche jamais au populaire
on connaît tous par le journal mais les
mots ça ne fait pas mal
on est toujours plus ému par ce qui est
loin mais on oublie la détresse de son
voisin on est miss trop bistrot
il se connaît pas trop patron
je cherche jamais pour pleurer
oh
je cherche mur pour plaire et on mélange
les accidents les princesses et leurs
prétendants on ne dit plus rien lorsque
des enfants fin mais on ouvre sa bourse
pour sauver des chiens on est tout tout
tout tout
on a bon coeur
c'est tout
7 je cherche jamais encore pleurer
je cherche à mes yeux pour pleurer
on ne perd plus part et ils en rigolent
et c'est plus facile on n'écoute plus
les poètes les airs ans on leur dit evo
vous n'êtes pas marrant on est et l'est
télé mais si fatigué de penser
je cherche à mieux pour pleurer
je cherche un mur pour pleurer on verra
la main socater ou bien nous bouffer du
curé mais en chantant coeur il est né
divine enfants
on va tous ensemble au muguet quand il
est blanc mondaine
rien
aia
dieu reconnaîtra
les siens
c'est
je cherche un mur pour pleurer
en
je cherche un mur pour pleurer on est
toujours que mon et pajot c'est reste un
jour ça va le seuil béat mais en a
jamais le temps on croit tenir la fleur
et on meurt mécontents on est
baumet
si on pouvait
s'aimer
mais
être ensemble pour pleurer nord
[Musique]
avoir le temps de pleurer